[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
standing at 28 feet and weighing in at
five tons the lw manonofu is a life-size
robot that was built by one man
a company that develops machines for
agriculture but they also make life-size
robots that people can operate for fun
and masaaki along with his colleagues
have built them all
to help promote the company he
referenced one of his favorite animes as
a kid right
but just building the robot wasn't
enough for masaaki he wanted something
that was bigger and better than his
previous models
he poured his heart and soul into making
the lw manonofu fully operational it
could move its arms
its legs
and has a gun that shoots spongeballs
it's his greatest creation yet
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i want to give the scrap life again
bring in a new purpose
my art is a mix of fantasy and common
sense
[Music]
my name is claudia coogler and i'm an
artist and i'm most known for making
moving robot sculptures
i stumbled into making robots
i was making sculptures out of scrap
metal i found and then i started to move
those moving parts with air pressure
pistons
it started with a head moving as a jaw
and
before i knew it i had a robot
[Music]
i find my scrap metal pretty much
everywhere i have got my eyes open all
the time potentially
fantastic eye
[Music]
there's every kind of shape you can
imagine
[Applause]
[Music]
when i built a band member i start
obviously with the music making parts of
fingers plugging or playing and then i
build
the character behind it
the special thing about my robots is
that they actually do play the music
themselves
[Music]
my robots play the bass guitar the drum
kit and they play the flutes
[Applause]
they got an affinity for punk rock
the whole band is called the one love
machine band
my robots perform all around the world
tech events
festivals university lectures or ted
talks
when people see the robot it's like they
freeze for a while there's this moment
of oh what's going on here and then it's
usually so it's a childish gleam and
the joy
i like to use scrap micro because
there's so much waste in the world
you can't destroy you can only make it
better
my work is a constant game of chance and
that's what i really love about it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
h
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the most important thing to know if you
only know one thing is that disaster
robots make the disaster go away faster
[Music]
my name is robin murphy i'm a professor
of computer science and engineering at
texas a m and i work with disaster
robots
1995 the oklahoma city bombing happened
one of my grad students went up and
helped and he came back and said we've
got to do it differently we could have
had robots like are being designed to go
to mars to get into places where people
and dogs can't go
[Music]
what we're talking about are robots
either ground aerial or marine robots
that can help responders do things that
they can't do any other way
and so in 1995 we all started working
toward disaster robots
it was 2001 before we actually used one
that was the first use of ground robots
for a disaster
it's the ability to do things you
couldn't do any other way they needed to
get more than 18 feet into the rubble
robots can go into these places to get
to where there might have been survivors
if i can see what i need to see i can
make good decisions to keep the
responders safe
so this is the part where we make fun of
me for driving
so notice that right now i'm driving
heads up
but really the trick of a robot is to
get out get beyond visual line of sight
because that's really the point
[Music]
disaster city is one of the emergency
management complexes that texas a m has
it's designed to test and to train
search and rescue teams on how to
conduct search and rescue missions
we've supplied robots for 28 disasters
earthquakes hurricane harvey we assisted
with the fukushima diachi nuclear
accident
[Music]
when we go we bring robots and people
that we've tested and practiced with in
our training exercises
one of the biggest challenges to doing
work in rescue robotics is not the
robotics it's the everything else
you're going to a different world
it's really challenging to be at a
disaster
there's a
physiological and psychological
impact of that
it really takes quite a toll
so you have to be really good at what
you're doing
but my job is so incredibly fulfilling
it's about the science and the
technology and the way it could be used
for societal good
that's a big deal to me